We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David p the number is available
to you anytime of day. It's also available
for whatever reason you want. If you have
something you want to ask about that's not
directly related to politics, if I find it
interesting, I might still answer it. And
here's one such example. Take a listen to
this voicemail.
Hey David, do you believe that baseball was
better during the steroid era? I hear that
argument and um, uh, quite frankly I simply
don't buy it because I have integrity for
the game.
Yeah. Uh, you know what, I was significantly
more into baseball during the steroid era,
but it didn't have anything to do with the
steroids. It was just, I had more time to
sit around and watch close to 162 baseball
games a year for the red sox. And I just followed
it much more closely. So I'm sort of the wrong
person to say, oh, that baseball was better
during the steroid steroid era or it is better
now. Um, in the limited baseball I watch it,
it does seem very anecdotally that there are
fewer homeruns being hit. And my guess is
that some portion of that would be related
to the crackdown on steroids and the realization
that a a whole hell of a lot of those people
hitting 40, 50, 60, or more home runs a year.
We're juicing. Um, I think that, uh, the,
the, what's important to me is that there'll
be some kind of a level playing field.
Okay. So if baseball said, uh, listen, steroids,
that will help you in some ways. And in others
it's skill and it's practice and here is the
list of sort of approved substances. I really
wouldn't have a problem with that. Like we
could make arguments about purity of the game.
We could make arguments about, well, the records
now have to be considered different than the
records 80 years ago because of the substances
that are now available. Those are all legitimate
arguments. And quite frankly, I'm fine saying
let's just do it a clean game. No steroids
whatsoever. But I don't think there's anything
objectively wrong with saying this is a sport
that allows the following performance enhancements
and that's it. When you think about even just
what we know about nutrition for baseball
players, maybe more relevant in other sports,
uh, basketball, football, whatever. You can
argue that the gains that are had via our
knowledge of nutrition today are also in a
way responsible for so many of the records
of 80 years ago being broken.
It's not performance enhancing in an illicit
way, but it is also a sort of better understanding
of science and substances that allows players
to do things that players were not doing 80
years ago. There's also some interesting statistical
stuff related to why does it always seem that
previously unsurpassable records are surpassed
and there's some interesting statistical stuff
there that is sort of beyond the scope of
this segment, which I find interesting and
encourage you to check out. But, uh, I don't
really care that much about steroids in baseball.
I watch very little baseball either way. Uh,
when the red sox do well, I, uh, start following
and otherwise I'm just sort of too busy. But
for me personally, I was definitely paying
more attention to baseball during the steroid
era, uh, but not because of the steroids,
just because I was in college and everybody
around me was watching every red sox game
and it was a big part of my social life. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. We will
talk about states considering revoking religious
vaccine exemptions. Uh, we will also talk
about a Denver vote this week on decriminalizing
a hallucinogenic mushrooms, which we've been
following actually since the beginning. And
we'll also talk about Democrats at faltering
in voter enthusiasm for 2020, which could
be a problem. All of those stories
and more, uh, and I will be joined by producer
pat in his new role, a supervising producer
of the David package. In mere minutes on the
bonus show, make sure you a member in order
to act.